Tonight.
We also have stunning information
about a
systematic program
run by the Russian government
to take Ukrainian children
and reeducate
and indoctrinate them
in camps in Russia and Crimea.
Some of the kids are believed
to have been given weapons
training and others
have been sent to live
with foster families
or even put up for adoption in Russia.
There's a new report
documenting a network of camps there.
43 of them in all across
Russia, occupied Crimea,
where thousands of Ukrainian children
have so far
been taken against international law.
So there's a lot to get to.
Tonight,
we begin with the story
behind the missile attack
on the aid workers.
And we warn you,
some of the video
you'll see is hard to watch,
seeing as Matthew Chance
did the reporting. He joins us now.
What more can you tell us
about this attack?
Yeah, an absolutely terrible attack,
of course.
And colleagues of Pete
Reid now saying that they believe
he was the victim
of a targeted strike by Russian forces
using a laser guided
anti-tank missile to think about.
The important thing
about those kinds of weapons
is they require line of sight, Anderson,
so that very deliberate indeed will say
that is now obtained
exclusive video of the actual moment
that took place on February the second
a short time ago.
And again, colleagues of Peter
Reid saying it
underlines and illustrates the despicable
tactics, as they called it,
being used by Russia against medics
in the war zone.
These are the final seconds
before volunteer medics in Ukraine,
including American Pete Reid,
seen here exiting the white van
come under vicious attack
The images obtained exclusively by CNN
show the explosion
ripping through the scene,
leaving Reid among the dead
oh, oh, oh.
But incredibly,
you can also hear
the screams of survivors
survivors like a volunteer
from Estonia
witnessing all of this
from just feet away.
Yeah.
The last one second that I remember
before the blast
or when the blast happened,
I saw the big ball of flame
and
it was like instantly
my fault for the darkness that can be
Volunteer medics working in Mount
are no strangers to the extreme violence
ravaging this city.
Fierce fighting for control,
making it one of Ukraine's
deadliest frontline
soldiers, dubbing it a meat grinder
But the parts of town
where the medics were answering
their emergency call on February
the second seemed relatively calm.
So that when you arrived at the scene
where you'd had
these reports of casualties
and you saw the casualties there.
Was there any fighting going on?
Was there any artillery shells coming in
close by that you would have
would have made you aware
that this was a particularly
dangerous spot?
No, no,
it was it was actually awfully quiet.
There
Didn't get no warning,
because usually
you can hear
when when the rounds come in,
you can hear the whistling noise
that determines that there is some
mortar or artillery shell coming in.
There wasn't nothing like this.
And he catches the exact moment
on his own cellphone
a frame
by frame analysis shows
what military experts
tell CNN is an anti-tank missile
striking the vehicle
a weapon that requires
line of sight
targeting to be this accurate.
Minutes later,
the medics
dash cam records a second strike a
slow motion revealing it's yet
another anti-tank missile.
It was observed and aimed directly
and to be sure that it's going to be
perfect hit.
They waited until the complete
stop and
after that, they instantly fired.
So do you think you were deliberately
targeted by the other side?
Yes, I think that there is
not much of a debate about it.
They shot two different
vehicles to try to hit another one also.
So they were ready.
They were prepared.
Russia has repeatedly
denied deliberately targeting civilians,
but over this gruesome
video of the aftermath,
the Russian private military company
Wagner says the volunteer medics
were foreign mercenaries
hit by what he calls an accurate strike,
even for humanitarian volunteers.
In this part, meat grinder protection,
it seems, is scarce
Think it's so incredibly only shot
this video
just one more time
in this targeted attack
because you get a sense
just how quiet it was right before this
And there's no there's
no indication that this is about
to happen to the rescue worker
who spoke to give it
any more clarity about
why the Russians might be targeted
targeting medics in this area.
They did.
Yet you're right to point out
how quiet it is.
I mean, I've been to myself
and it is extremely noisy
when there is fighting going on.
And so it really is striking
the silence that you can hear
sort of in the background there
in terms of,
you know,
why they would have been targeted.
Well, what the medics say is that, look,
the Russians know
very well
these volunteers
from the United States,
from other countries,
are doing an enormous amounts
of good to the civilian population
inside these areas.
Sometimes they're the only
sort of medical presence on the ground.
And the Russians,
they say, are determined to stop that.
To to take that away
to deter these people
from going to the front lines.
The medic
I spoke to in that report, Marco,
said, for his part,
it's not going to work.
He's determined to go back and says,
he'll be back near the front lines
in just a couple of weeks Anderson.
Wow.
I just want to show a still image again
where you see that missile.
I've never seen an image like this
that it took me a while to
to actually even see the missile
once I realized
it was parallel to the ground.
You also see where Mr.
Reed and the others were,
the van that they were in
the medics were in.
I know the van that the
the man who pulled up
from the
who took the video was in
that was clearly marked.
Does did did the van that Mr.
Reed was in and the others
Pete Reed was into that was that
marked it all in as a medic fan?
It doesn't seem to be.
Does I mean, it looks like a white
civilian van.
I mean, I understand that inside it's
converted into into an ambulance,
but it doesn't have
the sort of big
red crosses
daubed on it that you might expect
in that kind of location.
Look, I mean, what the medics say
is that
there's no way
this could have been mistaken
for anything
other than an ambulance
simply because these medical teams, Pete
Reed included
had been working in Bermuda
for months upon months.
And the Russians knew
very well
what they were doing,
what these medical sort of volunteers
of the kind of action
they've been involved in
and the kind of way they work.
They say there's no way
this could have been mistaken
for anything
military at all,
which again,
underlines for them
this idea
that they were particularly watched
and then targeted by Russian forces.
And as you said,
they tried to get another vehicle as well
with another missile.
Matthew appreciate the report. Thank you.